Now that we have our overhead lighting established, we want to start going in and adding various
different accent lightings to this vehicle.
Now if you've ever seen an actual photo shoot of a vehicle on a stage like this, you'll
know that there's various different lights that are placed throughout the different scenes.
We'll have various bounce light.
With all of the beautiful curvature of the automotive surface, we want to call out particular
highlights to various different things, whether it's new product shots, etc.
So to do that, we're going to use various different techniques of adding accent lighting
to our scene.
Now again, going back to some of these principles we've already been talking about, really this
is where the approach of isolating our lighting, testing it, disabling it temporarily to continue,
this is where it's very important.
We're going to be adding various different lights throughout our scene, and if our eye
is competing against lights that are turned on versus the specific light that we're looking
at, it's going to be very difficult to get that controlled look that we want.
So again, with this isolation method, we're going to disable our overhead lighting and
our skylight, and we're going to create our lights one by one.
Now if we do find that we put a lot of time and effort into creating a very beautiful
looking light, it's absolutely fine to go ahead and duplicate that and move it around.
Absolutely fine.
Once we're finished though, we want to make sure that we disable that light or those series
of lights that are closely related, and then continue to build onto our next.
Finally at the end of it, we're going to re-enable all of our lights and then balance our intensities
to bring them within tolerance.
Now again, we're going to use those calibration tools to make sure we're not overexposed or
underexposed with our lighting intensity.
And then lastly, we're going to use some various different fills and what we call kickers,
or just little lights to help bring attention.
There's a couple of little techniques I'm going to show you to be able to do that where
we don't inject too much specularity.
Yes, it is breaking some rules of science in convention, but that's absolutely fine
because we're working in digital medium, which means we can break the rules and it's absolutely
fine.
So for our scene, this is essentially what we want to build.
So you can see that we've we still have our overhead lights up above and we have various
different rec lights all around to kind of give these really nice, interesting highlights
and also driving various different intensities in our scene to accent our vehicle in the
middle.
So we'll go ahead and jump over and start building that now.
All right, so jump back over to our scene now to just help better visualize what we're
doing.
I'm going to go up to our outliner and I'm actually going to hide our calibration as
well as our notes folder.
And that should give us a fairly clean scene that we have here.
All right, so for this one, I'm essentially going to position my camera, you know, somewhere
relative to where I think maybe the final shot will be.
So we'll kind of use this, you know, semi low shot that we have as this.
So now what I want to do is go ahead and add some rec lights to our scene.
Now I'm not going to cover too many basic principles about lighting, whether or not
you use like three point lighting, Rembrandt lighting, all various different things.
It's really whatever medium or whatever your intended vision is.
But essentially, I'm going to reference a few key things here.
In particular, I want to make sure that I don't have super dark shadows.
And I also want to make sure I don't have too many lights.
So I'm going to do essentially what is a three point lighting setup.
So a light, our main light that kind of gets cast from our camera, maybe a side light from
our left and then a rim light on the back just to help separate the subject, which in
this case is our vehicle from the background.
All right, so I've dragged my rec light into the scene.
I'm going to press G to go into game mode.
I'll kind of move this rec light into place, kind of fly around here.
It's going to rotate and I'm going to go ahead and set it to movable just like we need to.
And I'm going to go ahead and adjust the width and maybe the height just a little bit.
Check where we're sitting.
All right.
And then maybe my barn door angle a little bit so we can see that in fact I'm rotated
180.
So we'll get this turned around.
And of course, this is very, very, very weak right now on our intensity.
So if I turn this off and on, you see we don't really notice much of anything.
All right, so I'll go and change this back to lumens and let's go ahead and change this
to something like let's just say a hundred thousand as our starting point.
Okay.
Clearly too bright so we can drag this up or down.
Maybe we'll do something like let's go like six thousand lumens.
Okay, that's still probably a little bright, but let's go ahead and get the light set up
and then we'll do a little bit of the balancing in a minute.
All right.
So if you recall with our principles of lighting, right now I'm trying to light the front of
this vehicle while I still have my overhead lights on.
So I'm going to select my two rec lights and then just disable them with the effects world
or I can simply hide them and see now all I have is this one.
Now we also have our panels illuminating so I can also hide these and now you can see
the actual light itself.
So with our overhead lighting on, you can see that it was quite deceptive in that the
light so this light that we're adjusting right now looked way brighter than it actually was.
So again, this is why we want to use that isolation approach.
All right, so I'll just go in here and just kind of adjust this light.
Now at this juncture, I could go in and I could add some color.
So if I select the color picker wheel, you see I can do this.
If you do decide to use colors, my best recommendation is avoid overly saturated colors because that's
really not natural.
But again, we're working a digital medium so if you want to, absolutely fine, break
the rules.
That's absolutely fine.
But for this one, I'm actually going to use the use temperature and you'll see here that
I can maybe warm it up.
This uses our Kelvin scale or cool it down.
I'm going to go something with let's say like 6000 Kelvin should be fine.
All right, so if you recall in our setup, so this is going to be like our main key light.
I could go in here, hold down alt and just drag this way.
Going to rotate this on the front of the vehicle and maybe I want to move this up.
Maybe I want to adjust this panel just a little bit more to give myself some height.
Again, the key is I'm looking for my reflections and the actual light intensity in the world.
And how I want to use that.
I will say that the energy fall off does look a little weak so I'm actually going to select
both of my rec lights and I'm going to go to my attenuation radius.
Let's go ahead and bump this up to 2500 and see starts to fill the scene a little bit
more.
All right, and then lastly, I'm going to go ahead and take this same light, duplicate
this, put it behind our subject and you can see we get that really sharp highlight.
Maybe I want to take this up a little bit and rotate it.
Now I'm going to switch from world units to local space.
I'm going to take this down, tilt it a little bit and maybe I want to move this up a little
bit more and maybe bump up our intensity to say something like 8000.
There we go.
So now we're starting to get some separation on the vehicle.
At this juncture, it's simply just a matter of balancing so I could go into here and maybe
move this light a little bit closer, something like this.
And now I'm starting to accent the vehicle a little bit more.
I can go back in, turn on my overhead rec lights and maybe my chimera panels and you'll
see now things are starting to really shape up in terms of accenting this vehicle.
Now just to show real quick, so I'm going to select the three lights that we just placed
and pressing G to go into game mode.
And if I hide these, you see this is what we started with and then this is with those
lights added.
So again, I could go back in here with my calibration tools, just double check that
you know, I'm within tolerances, I'm within the ranges that I need to and then make any
adjustments as necessary.
Now as a key learning point, if you did find that your scene was overexposed and what I
mean by that is with the lights being overexposed, it's just simply a matter of going in and
adjusting their intensity, right?
So each one is about 6,000 and our back one is at 8,000.
We could just lower those and then same thing with our overhead panels, adjusting those
as necessary.